hey guys I'm max Lasser and I'm do so
thanks for having me when I was watching
Star Wars rogue one I find myself
wondering whether the rebellion were
really the good guys in all this right
off the top I know that I'm about to say
some pretty terrible things about the
rebellion and it's all in good fun I'm
not a member of the Darth Vader Uther
Devo colonialist I just thought there
were some interesting elements of stuff
the rebels do that is a little weird and
now obviously this video is going to be
98% spoilers so if you hadn't seen it
turn away now first of all the Empire is
definitely pretty bad I mean we find out
in this episode that Darth Vader lives
in a lava castle I'm not even sure how
you would describe his vision for that
building to his architect without using
the word evil yeah so we'll go with a
sloping modern neo brutalist evil vibe
and for the bathroom I was thinking just
one giant two in the center because of
the movie is darker tone they were
willing to admit that it's pretty hard
to keep a rebellion comprised largely of
assassins and criminals from doing some
pretty morally questionable stuff and it
also seems like they don't have a great
plan in place for when they win I mean
it would be a shame if all those brave
heroes risked their lives for the Death
Star plans just so that Luke Skywalker
and some more brave heroes could risk
their lives to destroy it and everyone
on board just to create a power vacuum
that would only be taken over by another
all-black wearing military dictatorship
led by a red lightsaber wielding sadist
not to get three and a half episodes
ahead of myself now admittedly the
Empire kills billions of people and
controls the entire galaxy so you could
argue that it's worth doing anything to
bring them down but I just wanted to
consider for a moment how the rebellion
might have looked to a random shop owner
or bantha herder living in peace in the
Galactic Empire planet in the center of
the galaxy who just wants to feed their
family and send their kids to a good
Empire school one early example of just
what the rebels are willing to do for
the cause is casseon shooting his
samwell tarly s friend the informant in
the back just because he might want to
talk to the cops
this poor guy was literally out of
breath from running to tell kasi in a
secret and I know he was written to be
whiny and annoying but aren't these the
people the good guys are usually trying
to protect not shoot in the back now you
might say well Han shoots Greedo first
but Greedo
was an assassin sent to kill him not a
rebel informant who thought he was on
Kassian side if Bodhi was a hero for
smuggling Imperial information isn't
this sweaty guy a hero too meanwhile jyn
erso daughter of imperial scientists and
architect of the Death Star which at
this point is actually under its
codename
Stardust's which is adorable has been
captured by the empire for being a
general criminal type now in a major
strike against the are the rebels the
bad guys gin is on her way to a labor
camp and I don't think there's any
example of a noble or not absolutely
monstrous labor camp but hey we never
get to see the inside so maybe they just
spend their day making TIE fighter
license plates
anyway Jin is rescued by the rebellion
well rescued by force some have call it
sort of a benevolent kidnapping okay
they went through all this effort to
rescue her the least Jin could do is
sort of come with them and hear them out
and hey we're all good guys here so you
didn't fear on different pages if we
disagree we can just go our separate
ways no hard feelings or not rebel
command informs her that the choices are
she goes along with the plan to help
find her father or shall be sent right
back to the labor camp where they found
her and it's a life of snoring tentacle
face roommates and TIE fighter license
plates for her and this is actually even
more sinister than it sounds because we
find out later in the movie a Jinnah has
been recruited so that the rebellion can
secretly kill her father right under her
nose and sure they don't tell her that
at the time but from the rebel commands
perspective the plan in the secret rebel
war room was to force a girl who hasn't
seen her estranged father in 15 years to
find her father so they can kill him
while she watches thank God later in the
series these guys color code themselves
as good guys with blue lightsabers
because I otherwise I might forget who
I'm supposed to be rooting for now seems
like a good time to go back and talk
about Palin as a father because it turns
out he is a member of the rebellion and
this guy is some weird parenting
strategies first of all he calls his
daughter Stardust and he calls the death
star Stardust which is a machine that
destroys entire planets and turns them
into dust and I'm not a therapist that
seems pretty screwed up to me and sure
maybe he called that on the off chance
that she would be a part of a secret
rebellion mission to seal the Death Star
plans like 20 years later and you'd have
to know which tape to pick out from the
Imperial library but that can't be good
for the psyche of a child to be called
the thing that's left after daddy's
machine kills everyone and I mean that
stormtrooper doll she's playing with a
stormtrooper doll while Galen is making
elaborate plans of what to do when the
stormtroopers show up to kill them all
which as far as I'm concerned would be
like Anne Frank playing with a little
Nazi doll and sure he used to work for
the Empire and she probably had the toy
for a while and my cry when it get to
take it away but talk
about mixed messages I mean it's no
surprise to me the gin grows up without
an interest in politics when at age six
life-sized versions of her dolls kill
her mom after being forcibly hired for
the help us kill your dad mission step
one is to find Sagar arrow now sagar era
is a rebel leader whose methods are so
extreme that he's been forced out of a
regular rebellion which has already made
it clear that they're willing to murder
their friends in the street and trick
recruits into helping murder their dads
but saw is even more extreme than that
sort of the isis to the rebellions
taliban the guy that maybe enjoyed
killing stormtroopers so much they start
to make everyone feel weird but he
wouldn't stop talking about it at dinner
and they kicked him out of the noble
rebellion announced they wanted to have
nothing to do with him until they needed
him for anything saw then immediately
lives up to his reputation
when defecting imperial pilot Bodie rook
shows up at his doorstep and gets
dragged around in a burlap sack and then
tortured by a tentacle truth-seeking
monster named bore gullet which by the
way everyone in sauce camp cannot wait
to see they keep chanting Bork all at
Borgata like this is the best possible
Tuesday night entertainment on the
planet and they don't even bother to
play bodis message that he's risked his
life to bring them before they knowingly
drive him temporarily insane and throw
him in a Cell
man have you guys noticed what it's like
to inform for this rebellion you either
get shot or dragged around and laughed
at as you're part of the day's shied
show entertainment this is all taking
place on the Imperial occupied moon of
Jeddah and this is another really
important point to me this moon is
basically under imperial martial law and
if you believe rebel propaganda
shouldn't that be like a hell escape on
earth I mean that sounds pretty
terrifying to me
so let's see what it's like to live
under imperial occupation versus say the
neutral trading points on the rings of
Katrine seems like martial law under the
Empire is actually a relatively normal
life in fact they let the blind Jedi
Temple worker turret in way openly
preach about the force on the ruins of
his Jedi Temple I mean they pretty
clearly have freedom of speech and he
and Vaes are allowed to openly display
their weapons these are people who kill
20 stormtroopers at the first
opportunity and no one is bothering them
under oppressive imperial rule and to
cap it all off the Empire doesn't appear
to have any rules governing open-air
tentacle street food which is the same
marie's of Catrin and in Jetta in fact
when saw says to Jin that Imperial flags
are now raining everywhere Jin simply
says that she can't tell because she
just
look up like should you be able to tell
at eye level that the evil empire is
totally ruling your lives and mean these
are the people were throwing morality
out the window to overthrow and this is
like they're doing a pretty good job at
keeping the peace now sure maybe it's
peace through terror as Galen says at
the start of the movie but didn't
Machiavelli say it's better to be feared
than loved and I'm not sure Sagar era
has a great high horse to stand on here
since he's one of the few movie
characters to enjoy a heroic noble death
and a frequent use of burlap sacks while
an empire squadron is on patrol they get
surprised attacked by some of saws men
and I'm not gonna fall anyone for using
guerrilla tactics against a much more
powerful and larger force but cassian
sees one of saws men about to throw a
grenade that might hit gin and just
shoots him in the chest
now caffeine might not have had a better
option here because he was trying to
save Jin's life but this is another
example of a larger point I'll be making
soon it's hard to keep the various
factions of this rebellion together and
probably if they had managed to drive
the empire off it would have been
arguing pretty quick about why some guy
from corporate shot their friend in the
chest and even if he was in the right
maybe the good guys in this movie could
like take a 10-minute break from killing
and betraying each other even the
titular rogue one mission is an example
of how poorly run this operation is
because it counts it decides that based
on the unproven information they have
they can't risk sending fleets to scare
up to try to steal the Death Star plan
so this whole thing only works because
the rogue one team ignores the
higher-ups completely and while are
having this incredibly important debate
who gets all the floor time to give the
rousing speech about hope gin the
arsonist and robber who they hired to
kill our own dad I mean it sure would be
great if anyone on this rebel council
could display some leadership ability
and maybe they're not the ones who are
gonna be in charge once they take
everyone down but if they are they're
not doing a very good job so far
another thing about all this it is
really we see stormtroopers serving a
lot of different functions tops prison
guards soldiers and the rebels love
killing them basically no matter what
their job is some of these guys that got
killed in the labor convoy probably
spend a large portion of their day doing
prison paperwork which is fine if like
stormtroopers aren't really people and
they're just evil white soldiers but a
lot of these guys are probably normal
Empire citizens who got drafted maybe
even as children and we're sort of
conscripted into service maybe even
non-violently just kind of cleaning
prison cells or doing paperwork or being
doctors but as the rebels are attacking
scare if at the end of the film we see
them having a
cute conversation about who gets the
most updated equipment having completed
stage one of the mission it's time for
project killed this girl's dad to really
get in motion here's the part of the
film that really blows my mind
first of all Intel's casseon that her
father left her a message and they loves
her very much and also left a glaring
weakness in the desk Stardust because a
he's a loyal member of the rebellion and
B he knew that with or without him the
Empire would finish the project
eventually and we know that because we
just watched them blow up a city isn't
it time for somebody to update the
mission parameters and casseon still
wants to go forward with murdering Galen
even after knowing he's been a spy on
the inside the whole time and now they
want to kill him while his daughter is a
five-minute walk away now of course
casseon backs out at the last second but
still if I was Jim this guy would not
have been my top choice for hand-holding
on nuclear warfare beach but the rebel
command who were hopefully could do a
better job than the empire since they're
trying to overthrow them decides they
still need to kill him attacking a
science base and loosing a bunch of
rebel soldiers in the process and I
really feel bad for Galen because if he
is known he was going to be killed by a
rebel soldier he would have given his
daughter a rebel soldier doll to play
with I cannot get over that doll up to
this point what I've been trying to
convince you of is that the rebels do
whatever they want in the name of the
rebellion and it's frequently not great
but right before the rogue one crew
leaves casseon basically says that
himself they've all done kind of gross
stuff in the name of the rebellion and
if they ever had to stop like if the
rebellion ever ends and they just go
back to normal lives all that murdering
the name of the rebellion is now just
murdering and this brings me nicely to
my second main point what everyone is
doing all of this for what happen if the
rebellion would actually succeed let's
pretend for a second that the rebel
command were actually geniuses and right
the whole time and that killing Galen
halted the progress of the Death Star
and somewhere down the line they're able
to defeat the Empire's fleet and take
over the galaxy themselves or install
someone else but we'll talk about that
in a bit at that point
soccer era would still be alive and
we've seen in our world what happens
when a violent rebellion throws out the
current order without a solid plan for a
transition of power that's frequently an
absolute mess I mean if you look at the
Arab Spring which is a revolution that's
sought to unseat a dictator and it was
sort of a coalition people who just
wanted to see a new government in place
by the time all the
dusted settled the Muslim Brotherhood
had managed to take power and probably
Sagar era faction would have been pretty
loud in the discussion of who gets to
run what the guy with two tubes on his
face probably would've ended up being
under secretary of agriculture and when
sauce faction used their naturally
brutal methods to stay in power they
would have faced their own rebellions
and how much different are you from the
Empire at that point if you're willing
to work with these kind of people in
order to maintain control and reach your
ends like what is the rebellions Rand
plan they do succeed who is the plan for
who's gonna govern when they win yes
they very heroically managed to get the
death star plans and Luke Skywalker very
heroically manages to blow up the Death
Star but it's a lot easier to kill
people in charge than to leave after the
rebellion finally succeeds at the end of
episode six is it really any surprised
by the time Luke Skywalker's an old man
the dominant power in the galaxy is run
by another guy who's so insecure that he
has to change his boys and posts and I
really want to hit this point again
because it's not just that the rebellion
is incompetent it's that when you'd
oppose a violent dictator with no plan
for what's going to come after him
frequently it can be worse than it was
before when a rebellious faction
conspired to assassinate Caligula in
Rome within two generations he was
replaced by Nero who is yet another
megalomaniacal status which by the way
is pretty much what's happened so far in
Episode seven and there might have been
some pretty positive side effects to the
entire galaxy being under the Empire's
rule it's no longer canon but in the
Star Wars extended universe novels the
galaxy is frequently under attack from
extra galactic forces like the Yuuzhan
Vong there's even a theory that the
reason Emperor Palpatine was uniting the
galaxy and creating all these machines
of war in the first place was to fight
off galactic invaders because if evil
bug monsters from beyond the outer rim
come to kill everyone it sure would be
good if we were all on the same team in
fact threats from other planets is
probably the only thing keeping a lot of
these planetary governments together
earth is currently 270 countries so
before all doramas going to get blown up
by the Empire the planet of Alderaan was
probably 270 Alderaan countries so again
the fact that the Empire has all of the
galaxy's resources consolidated in one
place does have some positive side
effects it's like they always say any
[ __ ] can blow up a Death Star but it
takes a carpenter to build one and if
you take away to genocide it's a pretty
impressive feat of military engineering
so yeah why is even worth taking down
the Empire anyway the rebels in the bag
guys end of story except that the empire
are Nazis whoo hey alien so even though
a lot of what I said is true you got to
kind of give them a pass on whatever
they want to do because the end of the
day they're trying to take down Nazis if
you notice the Empire has basically no
aliens in it at all the Empire looks
like your stepfathers golf friends and
to the rebellions credit they have
aliens in the army aliens on the council
and they even have a little alien
Admiral and they make them a chair so we
can see the battle so you can sort of
think of this movie as the Star Wars and
glorious bastard a bunch people doing a
lot of screwed up stuff does it innocent
people but who cares because they're
doing it to Nazis and we have to live in
concert with our alien brothers et phone
home and I know what you guys are gonna
say you're gonna say they do have an
alien what about Admiral Thrawn but who
asked me being the one alien as part of
a group is trying to kill and
discriminate against aliens makes you a
little bit of an uncle frog so anyway
what we've learned in this video is that
even though eight-year-old me thought
that if I was in the Star Wars universe
I'd be Luke Skywalker 25 year old me is
more of a concern galactic citizen
writing an op-ed for the Corazon Times
which probably isn't great I've been max
placer and I don't have a Twitter but if
you want to leave comments trying to
convince me to join the light side you
can find me on Facebook or at Lasser max
on instagram and leave a comment guess I
missed something terrible that the
rebellion did because much like the
Galactic Empire
we encourage free speech and please if
you're trying to convince people to the
dark side go ahead and hit share like
the video send it around and subscribe
to new rock stars for all kinds of Star
Wars and non Star Wars stuff bye
you